this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four-hour body this is
more than 10 years ago and i did not get
paid to do so with approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very hard
pressed to find a more nutrient dense
and comprehensive formula on the market
it has multi vitamins multi-mineral
greens complex probiotics and prebiotics
for gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet friday my very own email
newsletter it's become one of the most
popular email newsletters in the world
with millions of subscribers and it's
super super simple it does not clog up
your inbox every friday i send out five
bullet points super short of the coolest
things i've found that week which
sometimes includes apps books
documentaries supplements gadgets new
self experiments hacks tricks and all
sorts of weird stuff that i dig up from
around the world
you guys podcast listeners and book
readers have asked me for something
short and action-packed for a very long
time because after all the podcast the
books they can be quite long and that's
why i created five bullet friday it's
become one of my favorite things i do
every week it's free it's always going
to be free and you can learn more at tim
dot blog forward slash friday that's tim
dot blog forward slash friday i get
asked a lot how i meet guests for the
podcast some of the most amazing people
i've ever interacted with and little
known fact i've met probably 25 of them
because they first subscribed to five
below friday so you'll be in good
company it's a lot of fun five bullet
friday is only available if you
subscribe via email i do not publish the
content on the blog or anywhere else
also if i'm doing small in-person
meetups offering early access to
startups beta testing special deals or
anything else that's very limited i
share it first with five bullet friday
subscribers so check it out tim dot blog
forward slash friday if you listen to
this podcast it's very likely that you'd
dig it a lot and you can of course
easily subscribe any time so easy peasy
again that's tim dot blog forward slash
friday and thanks for checking it out if
the spirit moves yeah
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissues
[Music]
[Music]
well hello boys and girls ladies and
germs this is tim ferriss welcome to the
tim ferriss show where it is usually my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out their routines
habits etc that you can apply to your
own
life this time around we have a very
special edition of this podcast
featuring two of your favorite guests
from the past dr mark plotkin and
hamilton morris mark takes over my
duties as host and interviews hamilton
for an episode of the plants of the gods
podcast you my dear listeners are
hearing this audio before anyone else so
it's a tim ferris show exclusive i've
previously featured some of my favorite
episodes from the plants of the gods
podcast here on this podcast and you can
find all those at tim dot blog
plants of the gods these episodes cover
a lot of fascinating ground so let's get
to the bios who is mark if you don't
know mark on twitter at doc doc mark
plotkin is an ethnobotanist who serves
as president of the amazon conservation
team which has partnered with roughly 80
tribes to map and improve management and
protection of roughly 100 million acres
of ancestral rainforests he is best
known to the general public as the
author of the book tales of a shaman's
apprentice one of the most popular books
ever written about the rain forest his
most recent book is the amazon what
everyone needs to know you can find my
interview with mark at tim.blog
mark
that's m-a-r-k-p-l-o-t-k-i-n
and the guest his guest today is
hamilton morris love hamilton hamilton
on twitter at hamilton morris
m-o-r-r-i-s
is a chemist filmmaker and science
journalist graduate of the new school he
conducts chemistry research at st
joseph's university hamilton is the
writer and director of the documentary
series hamilton's pharmacopia from a
copia depending on how you like to say
it in which he explores the chemistry
and traditions surrounding psychoactive
drugs very often subjecting himself to
personal intake you can find my most
recent interview with him at tim dot
blog slash hamilton and what you're
about to hear is a tightly packed 60
minute interview mark and hamilton cover
the history of different psychoactive
substances timothy leary's legacy the
drunken monkey hypothesis conservation
microdosing the differences between five
meo dmt that's 5-methoxy
dimethyltryptamine and dmt a disease
that afflicts people who smoke enormous
quantities of cannabis yes really the
impact of the placebo effect synthetic
versus natural options in this
psychoactive spectrum of things the role
of ritual and much much more please
enjoy
well hamilton i want to thank you for
agreeing to do the interview
and i would like to start by talking
about the sonoran desert toad
which as you know is an object of
fascination uh
not only regionally but certainly
nationally and perhaps internationally
so
perhaps you give us some thoughts on
this recent fascination with this
intriguing creature
yes it really does seem to be gaining
popularity
every time i think that it's peaked it
gets more and more popular and
in the last month there were two major
articles that came out
one day after another in the new york
times and the new yorker the new york
times one actually
was
largely focused on conservation issues i
thought that was pretty responsible in
its orientation the new yorker one was
more a profile of octavio rettig but i
think that even though it wasn't focused
on conservation
implicitly a lot of those issues were
evident
if only in terms of the magnitude of
his work how many people i think he
claimed to have personally turned on 10
000 people
and so
if you want to use a rough estimate that
each mature
buffalo various toad when milked if all
of the glands are milked could produce
enough venom to supply five people
that's you know the milking of two
thousand toads from one man
and
you add to that his partner jerry
sandoval or his former partner
makes at 4 000 toads and then everybody
else was inspired by them
you can just easily knock that up to 10
000 toads and i think it becomes clear
that even if it wasn't a problem for a
few people to do this if it continues to
gain popularity at the current rate it's
going to become a problem very quickly
there's an excellent ethnobotanist by
the name of gary nabhan very prolific
but his best book
my favorite is called the desert smells
like rain came out about 40 years ago
and it talks about how the hohokum
people have expanded agriculture in the
desert
and this apparently has expanded the
habitat for this toad but i think as
you're pointing out that there'd be a
lot more habitat needed to support this
toad and i know you've been one of the
leaders in terms of natural product
chemistry and recreating some of these
chemicals in the lab so i wonder if you
could share with us your thoughts on the
role of the chemist in terms of taking
the heat taking the pressure off natural
populations of plants animals and fungi
yeah i mean it's an interesting time
because
a lot of these things can be synthesized
somewhat trivially in an industrial lab
with the appropriate resources so
something like ibogaine to produce it
fully synthetically would be
totally
impossible for
a normal person to do
on a you know multi-gram scale to supply
a clinic or something like that but
if it were you know a large industrial
manufacturing operation it would then be
possible and that was what howard
lotsoff was trying to do with ibogaine
uh the same is not true of something
like 5mu dmt it's synthetically more
approachable which is really nice this
is one of the advantages is that it
could be produced
industrially for a pharmaceutical
company there's actually quite a few
different pharmaceutical companies right
now that are pursuing 5meo dmt as a
therapeutic
product
and all of them are using synthetic
material which i think is really a good
thing actually a necessary thing because
there's no way that
the toads could
supply a pharmaceutical demand
but what's nice about this is that
there's a sort of intermediate that
exists it doesn't need to be
pharmaceutical and it doesn't need to be
extracted from a toad it's possible for
somebody if it is done legally in a
region where they won't potentially lose
their freedom for doing this it's
possible to produce it synthetically in
a one-step reaction starting from
5-methoxytryptamine
and
this is very approachable somewhat safe
chemistry i don't want to say that it's
completely safe because it isn't but
i would say in the
grand scheme of synthesis this is
certainly on the easier side of the
balance and
that means that you know if somebody
were operating a clinic in mexico they
conceivably could hire a chemist to
make enough to supply their clinic for
years very easily at a low cost and that
was what i was trying to show people
because this idea that okay chemistry
there's no way that's not accessible to
an average person well maybe not to
everybody but it is accessible to people
with a little bit of training and so
people should be aware that that exists
as a viable option
well you mentioned howard's name and i
heard you talk a bit about them in an
interview you gave with our friend tim
ferriss and i'll link to that interview
in the show notes but i wonder if you
could tell a little bit of background
about howard's story and how he
discovered that this was in some cases
an effective treatment for addiction
yeah it's a fascinating story because if
you look at the history of iboga and
even the the early pharmaceutical
history of ibogaine
in
central west africa it's a religious
sacrament and part of a religion called
buiti
and it's used for medicinal purposes
there but it is not traditionally used
as a treatment for addiction
uh there was not opioid addiction in
central west africa until the 21st
century
so at least on a large scale i'm sure
there were you know a couple people but
um
so this idea that
ibogaine or a boga could serve as a
treatment for substance abuse disorders
was
not something that was circulating at
all and there was a guy in new york
named howard lotzoff who was friends
with a chemist
and the chemist gave him ibogaine
because it was a psychedelic that was
available i believe that he had either
synthesized it or ordered it ordered it
from a chemical supply catalog
and
howard lotzoff was
dependent on heroin at that time and he
took the ibogaine
not because he wanted to stop using
heroin necessarily he just wanted to use
a psychedelic
and what he found in the wake of that
experience was that he lost his craving
for heroin
and not only did he lose the craving for
it the very way that he conceptualized
the heroin had changed he didn't think
of it as something that was desirable or
good he started to think of heroin
as
essentially a symbol of death something
that
was
not only did he not need it he didn't
want it either and this was something
that emerged accidentally this was a
serendipitous discovery he wasn't
looking for this but he found it and
what he experienced was not unique
other people tried ibogaine and a boga
for the same purpose as a treatment for
addiction and it was found to be the
case that actually quite a large number
of people responded similarly and this
has even been demonstrated in animal
models of addiction so this is a
demonstrated effect it doesn't work for
everyone all the time but it seems that
maybe a solid third to a quarter of
people that undergo this therapy are
able to stop using
heroin or other opioids well there's
many fascinating nuggets of information
tucked in that answer but one that
stands out to me
is that this is a powerful and effective
use for something that the indigenous
peoples weren't using it for
and so what the the point of this and i
think the relevance for this podcast is
that not only are these mind-altering
substances important and useful for
things they've always been used for but
there's new things that come to the fore
i'm reminded of charles nichols at lsu
who's using tiny doses of hallucinogens
to treat asthma and they're not causing
hallucinations and i'm wondering if you
think that this kind of explains this
whole microdosing
movement that people aren't really sure
how it works or what it's for but people
seem to like it and find it effective
for a variety of purposes
well yes that's micro dosing is
difficult to talk about because it
doesn't really have a precise definition
so what i might call microdose could be
completely different especially when you
factor in
the
issue that
psilocybin-containing mushrooms and lsd
are the two psychedelics that people
typically have access to and both of
these are psychedelics where people do
not know the precise dose of chemical
they're consuming due to variation in
mushrooms and due to uncertainty about
the concentration on blotter so
you might say a microdose is half of one
tab of a blotter but you don't know how
much lsd is on that tab so it could be
completely different for some people a
microdose is a low dose of a psychedelic
for some people they define microdoses
subperceptual and in the research that
has been done thus far it seems like
it's a placebo effect but that's not to
say that low doses of psychedelics
couldn't
have some kind of therapeutic property
under the appropriate circumstances and
like you said the work of chuck nichols
is great evidence of that so maybe the
other thing is that you know what the
the therapeutic endpoints aren't well
defined in a lot of these micro dosing
you know what is it exactly that people
are looking for enhanced creativity
enhanced focus enhanced energy mood lift
i mean people uh seem to be pursuing
micro dosing for an almost unlimited
number of different applications and so
maybe it works for one thing for one
person maybe somebody with uh
you know suffering from chronic
inflammation with a certain psychedelic
could
have some benefit and maybe for someone
else there would be no benefit at all so
i think the real issue with talking
about microdosing is a lack of precision
in the definition of what a microdose is
what psychedelic is being used and what
the application of that microdose of a
psychedelic would be excellent thank you
which ties back into something else
you're alluding to the famous pamphlet
by albert most that you've helped bring
back to the fore
uh was actually written by ken nelson
and he's a fascinating figure in his own
right so i wonder if you could uh give
us a little bit of detail and background
on this incredible fellow yeah and it
was nice to see his name in these
articles it's nice to really see him
integrated into this history because
i think what he did is so fascinating
and
um you know i think that because our
culture has done such a terrible job
dealing with psychedelics and
psychoactive drugs in general it's just
about
as bad as it could possibly be
locking people in cages for using them
is really has not
been an effective strategy and for that
reason i think we tend to look to
indigenous cultures for guidance because
they've done a far better job at
learning how to use these things
constructively and medicinally and so
we're almost uncomfortable with
our own contributions i think there's a
tendency to
try to exclusively look some people go
too far and in the case of boof
walvarius i think that they have done
that they have essentially fabricated an
indigenous history of use because
if it's ancient if it's traditional if
it's indigenous that means that it's
good that means that it's okay that
justifies it well
all known evidence points to there not
being a tradition of using buffalo
various this is something that emerged
in the united states with a
white man in texas named ken nelson who
was he was actually inspired by a
misunderstanding by an anthropologist
named jeanette runquist who had
hypothesized that there was ancient use
of psychoactive toads so he read about
this in omni magazine and thought well
that's cool uh i'd like to you know i'd
like to try that myself
not realizing that in his imitation of
what he thought was an indigenous
practice he was actually inventing a new
practice himself a very
interesting twist in all of this
and so he was
by all known accounts the first person
to
find this toad milk it and smoke the
venom and
at the beginning it was obscure there
were you know psychedelic cognoscenti
like andrew weil or wade davis who
pursued this and were very interested in
it but this was not a phenomenon the
celebrities weren't talking about toad
venom in the 1980s
and if it was popular it was probably
equivalent in popularity to synthetic 5
muodmt at that time which had been
available
from chemical supply companies since at
least the 1960s so
the synthetic
5-meo dmt history actually
predates the use of buffalo various
venom it just was never
talked about as much and there's
something i suppose something cool about
the idea of smoking toad venom people
like to talk about it we're talking
about it right now there's something
weird about it it's it's a good story
and
it wasn't until
celebrities really started doing this in
the 21st century and until octavio
reddick and jerry sandoval started going
on a uh crusade as toad venom
evangelists that this really became the
phenomenon that we're currently talking
about well that's a new phrase for me
toad venom evangelism i'm gonna have to
be lifting that one so why are people
calling this the god molecule versus
just plain old dmt
well the experiences are very different
this is one of the unfortunate things
about five meodmt is its name
people think that because the name
contains dmt that it is
a form of dmt or that it is you know
uh very very closely related to dmt but
cilicin you know the active metabolite
of psilocybin and a component of
psilocybin-containing mushrooms is
closer to dmt
than 5meodmt is structurally
you could call silicen for hydroxy dmt
so it's really the name more than
anything that i think
causes people to have this association
it was actually a big problem when i was
planning a large scale synthesis of five
meo dmt in mexico because the lawyers
looked at this and they said well this
is dmt and i'd say no it's not it's five
meow dmt it's five methoxy dmt and this
contains dmt in the name and i'd say
okay well what if i call it nno
trimethyl serotonin then can i
synthesize it and
they uh
they thought that was okay of course
it's the same chemical um so but the
difference experientially between five
amio dmt and dmt is enormous
i would say that dmt is
very much a prototypical classical
psychedelic it's
highly highly visual
you have profound visual distortions you
often
see you're an environment in a different
way you think about yourself your
relationships it's a personal experience
whereas 5miodmt
is often non-visual it's often
sort of impersonal i think it tends
toward universal where it's not about
your life but life in general
and
it doesn't have a lot of the qualities
that people think of when they talk
about psychedelic drugs i mean for many
people myself included the experience is
losing consciousness entirely for a
brief period and then having something
that could be termed a near-death
experience physiologically speaking it
isn't but experientially it uh does feel
that way well i want to make the point
here that we're not doing commercials
for any of these substances and in all
the episodes i point out that these
things can be lethal and you've
mentioned that on your show and in some
of your writings and interviews but even
of cannabis which people sort of think
of as this harmless thing that can't
hurt anybody and i was reading something
of yours recently that talked about
problematic relationships with cannabis
so i wonder if you could give an example
of that so that people understand that
all of these plants are the gods and
fungi the gods and frogs of the gods
may have a downside
yeah i think it's it's very important to
have a balanced perspective on these
things because there's been something
really polarizing about the way they've
been publicly discussed from the very
beginning they're either a panacea it's
going to cure all of society's ills
they're going to prevent us from being
mean to each other they're going to end
all wars or they're poisonous agents
that will destroy your mind and leave
you intellectually crippled and of
course the
truth is somewhere in the middle where
for some people under some circumstances
they can have a tremendous benefit and
they can be
truly life-changing and under other
circumstances they can have a damaging
effect and with you know cannabis i
think is an interesting example because
it also includes the political
dimensions of all this because the
people the people that have been using
these substances
for
decades have been persecuted
and
that creates a sort of insecurity
complex
understandably justifiably if the
government says
that this is dangerous and they're
willing to lock you in a cage for it if
your employer can terminate your
employment if they find traces of this
substance in your hair or your urine
which is an insane invasion of privacy
that nobody should tolerate
then it makes sense you'd want to really
stand up for this stuff and say hey wait
a second it's never killed anybody
it's safer than alcohol safer than
tobacco this stuff is innocuous
in fact you can smoke it every single
day and you'll be totally fine and in
many instances that might be true but
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
should and it doesn't mean that we i
think this is the tendency as we go too
far in one direction or another and a
lot of it has to do with this um yeah
this insecurity from people
demonizing these substances for so long
agreed but can you give perhaps an
example of a problematic relationship
with cannabis because
your your point is well taken but that
it's even cannabis can have a downside
oh certainly yeah i mean i think one of
the most interesting examples is there's
a
disorder called cannabis hyperemesis
disorder are you familiar with this
uh it wasn't described into in the
medical literature until somewhat
recently it's a very odd phenomenon
where people who smoke enormous
quantities of cannabis
will
start vomiting
continuously
and the only thing that relieves their
nausea is taking a hot shower
and
people started showing up in emergency
rooms when they ran out of hot water
because they couldn't control their
vomiting and
this seemed really bizarre because wait
a second people have been using cannabis
for thousands of years what are the
chances that
now all of a sudden a new cannabis
related disorder would emerge it
couldn't be the cannabis itself it must
be a pesticide it must be some
contaminant in the cannabis otherwise
how could this possibly be explained
and the explanation is that yes it is
the cannabis itself this is a product of
chronic hyperstimulation of cb1
receptors and the reality is that people
are smoking more cannabis now than any
other time in human history so new
use disorders are actually emerging and
although this is described as a somewhat
obscure phenomenon it's not as obscure
as people think i've known two people
that had this disorder both of whom
didn't know they had it and
and it's especially insidious because
cannabis has an antiemetic effect so
you're nauseous you think oh man i'm so
sick i uh i need to smoke some cannabis
because i'm really nauseous but the
cannabis is actually making it worse
it's the cause it's the source of the
nausea and this during the pandemic i
had a friend who this uh happened to
because he was just getting really
really stoned all the time and uh and i
had noticed that he was constantly
soaking wet
and i thought like why is this guy
is he like taking showers five times a
day why is he always so wet and
and he then told me you know i don't
know what's going on i've just been
you know vomiting all the time and a hot
shower is really the only thing that
that helps and i thought wow all right i
know what you have this is a so that's
you know to i don't want to bring that
up as an example of something that
everyone should be really terrified of
because this is something that only
afflicts people who are extremely stoned
all the time um
but it's just an example of how this
plant that's considered totally
innocuous
under some circumstances can have a
negative effect also i think there's
something to be said for
uh maybe just not being stoned all the
time and i say this is somebody that
likes cannabis personally i'm not trying
to hate on cannabis it's just there's
like i said a tendency to go to these
extremes of either cannabis is terrible
or you should be stoned all the time
because cannabis is a medicine
well my mentor richard schulte's would
often describe mind-altering plants as
scalpels in the hand of a shame and it
can heal but it can also harm if it's
not used correctly and so once again all
of these plants all of these fungi all
of these substances need to be used with
caution and approach with reverence
and carefully and that's why
i often tell people you shouldn't be
experimenting on your own with very
powerful substances
uh i also wanted to ask you hamilton
about other frogs before we move into a
few other
topics and that is when i was working on
a book called medicine quest about 30
years ago i interviewed john daly and at
that point 30 years ago a daily had
isolated 40 novel chemicals just from
frogs from 50 different species so i'm
wondering what's your perspective on
frogs and other plants animals and fungi
as to what's still out there um i love
frogs and they are
amazing chemists i mean
are you i imagine you're familiar with
epibatidine
it's such a beautiful molecule and for a
terrestrial species to even produce a
chlorinated natural product like that is
already sort of unusual then you have
the seven as a nor bornean ring which is
uh just
bizarre i mean the chemistry of it is
really really fascinating and these
frogs and toads are
capable of biosynthetic feats that
would be very difficult for human
chemists it's remarkable and
i don't doubt that there are amazing
things left to be discovered
well i
have read recent reports of two venomous
frogs found in eastern brazil
genus chorothromantis and a
parasphenidon where they have toxins
more poisonous than the bushmaster
and these are recent finds so the idea
that we've kind of got everything from
the natural world or even just from the
frogs is obviously not the case of
course the flip side of that is with
chytrid fungi and climate change these
animals which are probably the most
sensitive of any group so the race is on
is to find utilize and protect these
creatures at the same time that we seem
to be destroy destroying them faster
than ever there's about a thousand
species of frogs are known in the amazon
and we're finding more all the time
but i wanted to turn to uh one of your
uh
idols or mentors or heroes i don't know
how you'd best describe them alexander
shulgin better known as sasha and since
we're talking about mental states i
wonder if you share with us the story
about sasha and the surgery on his thumb
oh yeah yeah of course um and this is a
sort of foundational story in
psychedelic history because
alexander shulgin was in the navy
and
when he was in the navy he was injured
he injured his thumb
and
he was having i believe a small surgical
procedure maybe it was just stitches on
his thumb and
the nurse gave him a glass of orange
juice that had crystals that he could
see
present in the juice and he thought okay
well they're giving me morphine in my
orange juice makes sense this is gonna
be you know it's a painful procedure he
drank it and the morphine had this you
know miraculous analgesic effect and he
thought that was great that was exactly
what i needed
and later he asked the nurse you know
how much morphine was that in the juice
and she said oh no it was sugar those
are sugar crystals so he came to realize
that
his own mind was capable of producing
these sorts of experiences i mean this
is the placebo effect and it's very very
powerful and
as somebody who spent his career
evaluating completely unknown substances
substances that did not exist in the
known universe until they were
synthesized in his lab and he would be
the first human being to try those
substances you have to be ultra aware of
not just the placebo effect but also the
nocebo effect the uh
the belief that something that is
pharmacologically inactive that you have
consumed is a poison because it could go
either way you could take something and
suddenly think oh no what did i just do
oh no this could be some kind of cardiac
talks and i could be i could be dying
you can have a
both are totally possible and both are
established phenomena in the medical
literature this is not some kind of you
know speculative thing this is why
placebo-controlled
trials are done because the placebo
effect is a real effect this is one of
the complicated things about it
understood but we've got two pieces of
the puzzle that don't fit together well
here you have a man who invented more
wild mind-altering chemicals than
anybody ever had or ever willed and is a
big fan of the placebo effect so what's
the lesson we draw from his life and
work in terms of the future and healing
if we get this right
well i think the first thing is to
not always believe your own senses
immediately to scrutinize your own
experiences and to
try your best to
be skeptical and to
conduct your work in an evidence-based
manner because yes there is nobody who
is not vulnerable to the placebo effect
you might think oh that's just for the
people out there that don't really
they're not you know really
knowledgeable like me but someone like
me so knowledgeable i could obviously
tell the difference between a placebo
and an active substance well the whole
issue with placebo is that you can't
tell that's the whole purpose of this
effect and
so
i think this actually comes back to the
conservation issue because people will
say
uh well of course toad venom is
different than a synthetic material and
of course
uh
a boga total alkaloid extract is
different from isolated ibogaine and of
course uh one variety of
psilocybin-containing mushroom is going
to be different than another
well
not so fast if you're going to make that
claim especially if that claim could
have serious ecological consequences you
need to be sure that it's real well
everybody in our field is repeatedly
asked or told i would never take a
synthetic i will only take the natural
product so what's the difference between
synthetic mescaline and mescaline
[Music]
i i love that question because it's uh
you know it's there's a really beautiful
study that was done between two groups
of researchers one in
france and the other in germany and it
was a group of natural product chemists
in france who were studying a
traditional medicine in cameroon
called nalclea latifolia and they knew
that this plant had been used to treat
pain for generations so they brought it
to the lab they extracted it what's in
this stuff and they find that it
contains tramadol which is a completely
synthetic pharmaceutical opioid that was
thought to have been discovered in
germany in the 1960s so wait a second
there's now two parallel histories of
tramadol one that is pharmaceutical
starting in germany and the other that
is a multi-generational traditional
medicine history in
central west africa and this was kind of
a remarkable
claim it was very exciting to me but
then
a group of chemists in germany decided
that they were going to try to replicate
these findings they went back to the
same region they started collecting
samples and they found that tramadol was
actually distributed throughout the
environment and
then the question emerged okay so there
one group is saying this is being
biosynthesized by a plant the other
group is saying this is a product of
anthropogenic contamination of the
environment and if you're comparing
these two samples
what is the difference how would you
ever know and what it came down to was
radiocarbon because if something is a
natural product it will contain traces
of radiocarbon if something is
synthesized from petrochemicals it will
contain no radiocarbon so in the
strictest sense if you were going to say
what is the difference between synthetic
masculine and mescaline biosynthesized
by a plant hypothetically the
biosynthesized masculine would be
slightly more radioactive
but this is not not something that would
have any health consequence we're
talking about uh
amounts of radioactivity that are barely
detectable with the most sensitive known
analytical instruments um
but effectively you know the short
answer is nothing there's there's
nothing different but again back to the
placebo effect just because there's
nothing different about it doesn't mean
that you won't have a different
experience this is why it's so
complicated because this is dependent on
your values so if you're somebody that
really likes plants and you have a sort
of animist relationship with plants
where you see them as having a vital
essence of one kind or another and that
is important to you
then you are going to probably have a
better experience with plant derived
mescaline because of the associations
and the psychological priming associated
with that if you also think that
synthetic artificial substances are bad
and dangerous and undesirable you will
be inclined to have a negative
experience so it's again this is not to
say that people don't have different
experiences but that the experience is
psychologically mediated as opposed to
being mediated by the psychopharmacology
of these effectively identical
substances
which links to another issue that i want
to discuss
and that is that of ritual and the role
of ritual and the importance of ritual
the best description i was able to find
it was ritual is the performance of
ceremonial acts prescribed by tradition
or sacred decrees
so many of these traditional uses
involve a lot of ritual so what in your
view is the importance of this ritual in
terms of the placebo effects setting the
stage uh or convincing you of something
that might not happen without it um
i mean there's so many different
purposes that a ritual can have
depending on the ritual and the plant
and and what is being done and where
it's being done in the culture but
i think that ritual can be very
important for emphasizing and
accentuating certain dimensions of an
experience so
traditionally eboga was not used to
treat substance abuse disorders in gabon
but in recent years it is being used
that way and what really struck me was
that even without the ceremony being
explicitly oriented toward that purpose
i felt that something of that nature was
being implicitly communicated which was
a sort of
endurance feat where you dance
and you fast and you give yourself
entirely to this experience and because
you abandon comfort because you abandon
all of your
associations and everyday life
it
causes you to
rely on yourself in a different way and
i think that
that
could have a sort of anti-addictive
effect because it's it's you know
what we refer to as addiction in the
substance abuse sense i think is a
ramification of a far more common human
tendency which is a sense of being
dependent on anything it could be your
phone it could be someone that you're in
a romantic relationship with it could be
sweet foods it could be a specific
comfortable bed and you feel that if you
don't have that thing you're just
that's necessary for your life you're
not whole without it you need it you're
dependent on this external force and i
think that that ritual
emphasizes a certain
core independence and a
endurance and a feeling that you have so
much within you
that you can withstand the deprivation
of sleep or water because the reserves
exist inside you well again to to drill
down a little deeper on this when i was
in oaxaca 20 years ago i had the honor
and privilege of working with dhonia
julieta who certainly didn't get the
press that maria sabina did but the
local peoples considered her
every bit as powerful at one point she
told me she said you know before the
gringos started showing up here before
people like watson showed up here
we used the
the nino santos the little sainted ones
the mushrooms to heal and to search for
lost objects that was the two purposes
very different than what people are
going there for now
and so when i hear about people
starting to combine cannabis with
ayahuasca and things like this and
saying it's it's traditional
uh what are your thoughts on this sort
of combination of these different
traditions and these new uses it's oh
yeah it's it's really actually
remarkable i'm repeatedly surprised by
how common that has become and this is
something that's actually not talked
about i'm glad you brought this up um
because i'll talk to people and they'll
say you know i just did a
a
a combo ceremony with filamentous a
bicolor and i'll say oh where was it say
oh you know it was in brooklyn
and uh i'll say okay what was it like
and they say you know they gave me five
burns and then as soon as i had
recovered from the vomiting they gave me
buffalo various venom i'll say oh
so they're throwing that in the mix as
well and they'll say and then when i
came down from the buffalo various venom
they gave me synonga eye drops
and they'll think wow all right they're
just really giving you the whitman
sampling
and that is not uncommon i actually when
i talk to
people that are um
you know not a part of an indigenous
group but they've created a sort of uh
let's i it sounds mean but you know sort
of pseudo traditional pseudo-indigenous
practice where they use pieces of those
ceremonies but they're not actually from
those groups themselves and the way i
know that that sounds kind of unsavory
the way i just described it but i think
some of these people have good
intentions and they're not necessarily
harming anyone but they do tend to mix
and match these traditions in a way that
is
surprising to me i don't even want to go
so far as to say it's necessarily bad
but it's something that i would be very
cautious about and it is a i think cause
for concern because they'll do these
multi-day
multi-substance
retreats where you know day one you do
ayahuasca day two you do psilocybin
containing mushrooms then you do
ibogaine then you end the whole thing
with buffalo various venom and
i don't know i think your guess is as
good as mine when it comes to whether or
not that's a constructive practice i
also wanted to ask you one thing really
quickly so you were in outlaw in the
early 2000s
i'm curious so and maria sabino was dead
by then
um
and i'm curious what it was like then
it was sort of just becoming discovered
and i remember being in the plaza and
there would be people walking through
the plaza with uh plants of the gods the
schultes and the huffman book going like
i think i'll try that one sort of like a
chinese menu so it was changing at the
time tourists were doing this tourist
yeah gringos yeah but i was working with
a mexican physician who had lived with
the weech holes for eight years
and was actually uh dating the daughter
of the most powerful shaman
so i kind of sidled into a very
traditional healing tradition rather
than being all these guys who showed up
in the plaza looking for people saying
mushrooms mushrooms hong kong
so it was just at that cusp where things
were becoming more commercial and more
open to the outside world and as you
know
this type of psychedelic tourism
has positive and negative aspects and
that's one of the things i want to ask
you about
because you talked about good intentions
and michael pollan in his book talks
about the fact that a lot of people who
are
seeking out this psychedelic healing
tend to be people with emotional
problems who may not be all that
together
and are the ones most likely to come
apart if they're not under the care of
really a skilled practitioner who's not
in it for the money or just for the
money
so i i'd like to get your thoughts on
this type of psychedelic tourism and the
potential downsides and the real
downsides that you know we we see
yeah and this is one of the fundamental
changes that occurs in a medical model
if you talk to somebody like
william leonard picard who is a very
prominent lsd chemist and is considered
to have been responsible for producing
more lsd than any person in history
and his
philosophy when it came to the
distribution of lsd was you give it to
healthy people this is not a substance
that you give to somebody who just broke
up with their boyfriend or girlfriend
this is not something you give to
somebody who's mentally unstable this is
something that is used for the
betterment of healthy people and in a
medical model that is the complete
opposite and instead
these by necessity must be used for
treatment of disease because this is the
way our current medical system works
there is no provision for the use of
medicines by healthy people that's not
how health insurance works that's not
how the fda works for better or worse
and
uh and so
in these trials and at these retreats so
this occurs on both the gray market
black market and the medicalized market
there is a tendency for people who are
pursuing these things for treatment of
disease and you
run the full gamut of
problems that can come with that
i think on one end you have a lot of the
sorts of things that happen in the realm
of unregulated cancer treatments where
you have desperate people
because a lot of diseases will put
somebody in a state of serious
desperation you have a
terminal neurodegenerative disease you
want something that will halt that
degeneration and you'll try anything and
if somebody says hey
you know ibogaine is a treatment for
parkinson's disease which is a claim
that is uh made quite often and
the evidence for it is not very strong
i've actually talked about this in the
past and
is it possible that it could treat
parkinson's yeah i think it's possible
but there certainly isn't sufficient
evidence that people who have
parkinson's disease should take ibogaine
thinking that this is going to cure all
of their problems i mean it really has
not been adequately studied um so you
have that sort of thing happening and
then you have the
problems with aftercare with integration
where if somebody
you know has some kind of trauma and
they have this experience at let's say a
toad venom retreat then what is there a
follow-up no then they're on their own
and what and we don't live in a society
that
has
provisions for caring for people after
an experience like that which can be
really
disruptive to their functioning
i think this integration issue is much
overlooked in our field
uh my organization the amazon
conservation team does a lot of work
with the original iowa schedules and the
northwest amazon that chilties work with
in the 40s
and many times you'll finish a ceremony
and three days later you're walking down
the street and you'll get some
realization or you have some weird sort
of semi vision
and you're able to go back to the shaman
and say what does that mean and they'll
be able to explain to you usually but in
our culture where you go to the doctor
and then you're done what happens
afterwards it's your issue your problem
and these powerful substances in our
heads our minds and our souls if you
don't have somebody there guiding you
through the aftermath i think you're
kind of asking for asking for trouble
and i think again this is one of the
reasons why their medicine is effective
in some cases when ours is not
yeah
but
uh i'm just wondering if you think that
fungi are as promising as frogs in terms
of new substances new mind altering
substances new stuff for micro dosing
what's your perspective
well from a sustainability perspective
mushrooms are about as good as anything
anyone could ask for
and a lot of that has to do with the
natural abundance of proliferation of
different species and different genera
that produce psilocybin and that is a
product of people being obsessed with
mushrooms and searching for them
everywhere because this wasn't always
the case you know there was a time when
people thought this was exclusively
something that was found in oaxaca and
if you wanted to try psilocybin
containing mushrooms you had to go to
waula and it wasn't until people started
finding them in the united states
and more importantly until dennis
mckenna adapted laboratory techniques
for the cultivation of
psilocybin-containing mushrooms and
published in an underground
non-scientific guide intended for lay
readers that not only did people
recognize that these things grew
naturally in the united states but that
they could cultivate them themselves and
that really sparked a revolution that
dramatically increased the availability
of psilocybin-containing mushrooms they
went from something so obscure that
essentially nobody could try them to the
most common psychedelic and that was
exclusively a product of innovation
really scientific innovation and
cultivation techniques and i think that
that is why it's so important to think
about these things if people hadn't done
that it could have been very different
it could have been
even more overcrowding and tourism to
mexico if people thought that by
necessity they had to make this voyage
and instead it had a fact where people
were empowered to pursue these things
independently which i think can be a
very positive thing and the issue is
that we just haven't developed
equivalent techniques for a lot of these
other things that was sort of what i was
trying to do with 5meodmt it's a little
more complicated but if there were a way
to empower people
to
use these things sustainably then a lot
of these problems would go away
excellent point i mean we send
ethnobotanists to the jungle searching
for magic frogs and it turns out here
they are in arizona
richard schulte's left massachusetts to
the wilds oaxaca in 1936
in search of magic mushrooms but
according to giuliana ferci who was on
tim ferriss's show recently there's
probably 12 or 15 magic mushroom species
growing in massachusetts
so
on one hand it's a bit like the wizard
of oz there's no place like home but i
think that what it what it brings home
is that all species everywhere are
valuable and need to be investigated
so where do we look next for these new
and wild substances is the coral reef
is it the boreal forest you're the
natural product chemist what do you
think well to be i don't actually do all
that much work with natural products
almost everything that i do is a
synthesis of novel compounds although
i've done a little bit i've synthesized
five bromodmt for example which is the
only psychedelic that has ever been
isolated from a marine organism and it's
really the only known psychedelic from
the ocean and only the ocean
um i think it is possible that there
will be other marine psychedelics
discovered but again the same problems
emerge i mean thankfully people don't
really like five bromo dmt that much
because and also thankfully it's easy
enough to synthesize that nobody has
considered uh attempting to poach the
sponge source menospongia oreo um
but what if that were not the case what
if it were like 5mu dmt and it produced
a really remarkable life-changing type
experience and that would rapidly become
a conservation issue and you'd probably
run into the same phenomenon where some
uh
shaman or zelit would say well you know
look i found an ancient engraving of a
sponge and this shows that in fact
people have been using sponges for
thousands of years and it is our
ancestral responsibility to remove these
sponges from the ocean and figure out a
way to smoke their alkaloids i think
it's going to present a more challenging
case for these neo-shamans to claim that
it was always used as a hallucinogenic
by the indigenous peoples who lived on
the coral reef but time will tell
now i'm wondering if you have any
thoughts to share on the preponderance
of hallucinogenic substances in the new
world the new world tropics versus the
old world a lot of people have paid a
lot of lip service to this and i haven't
heard a convincing case as to why we
have so much from central and south
america and relatively so so little from
africa asia
i think one answer
seems to be that people have not looked
as hard i mean
people are finding new species of
psilocybin containing mushrooms there
was a species found in congo not so long
ago
that uh you know just it seems very
possible to me that nobody had
looked until somewhat recently there's
even evidence of traditional use of
psilocybin containing mushrooms in
uganda which would be really interesting
because that would suggest that
this is that there was maybe a parallel
evolution of psilocybin containing
mushroom traditions in both africa and
in mexico uh the the evidence for the
use in uganda is relatively slim but
there is one paper on it that suggests
that this could be the case uh yeah well
if you get me that reference put it in
the show notes because i'm sure that'll
uh
be of great interest to a lot of people
now
weston labar who was on schulte's early
expeditions to oklahoma in search of
peyote wrote a classic paper on the
shamanic origins of religion and
medicine
and i'm wondering if you have a personal
opinion or insight as to whether these
disciplines were essentially the same or
how much overlap there was thousands
tens of thousands or maybe a hundred
thousand years ago
oh well certainly traditionally there
would have been an enormous amount of
overlap depending on what culture you're
talking about as well
and i think that this is one of the
things about modern medicine that has
been lost is these
sort of ceremonial or ritual or
psychological dimensions to the
administration of a medicine which will
necessarily change the outcome i mean
they've even done
experiments with a
treatment for hair loss called
finasteride and they gave one group of
people
information where they said you know
this drug it's going to cause sexual
dysfunction it's going to
cause depression it's going to have some
negative side effects and the other
group they didn't say any of this and
the people had been told that there was
risk of these adverse effects experience
them more prominently so there's no
question that the way a medicine is
administered changes the outcome and
that's something that is not really
integrated into our current medical
practices
you have talked about the importance of
strytenose and strychnine in medicine
in surname where i've done a lot of my
work they have long sold a male
aphrodisiac tea
made from a species of strictness now i
don't know whether there's strictness in
it um and i'm not advocating the use of
street nose but i wonder if you could
elaborate on this use of poisons as
medicines and vice versa have you ever
tried it
i have not tried it yes i mean but yeah
strychnine was used as a medicine
it was actually used as a
performance-enhancing drug by athletes
whether or not that
is really uh effective for that purpose
is unclear to me obviously it's
potentially very unsafe but i think
strychnine is a really good example of
this you know foundational concept in
toxicology which is the dose makes the
poison there is nothing that is
inherently therapeutic or inherently
toxic these are all a function of dose
so there is a dose of strychnine that is
not dangerous to consume it's a very low
dose the therapeutic index of strychnine
is quite a bit lower than other
substances but that doesn't mean that it
is intrinsically a poison almost
everything that we call a poison under
some circumstances at least conceivably
could have a therapeutic effect
including radiation so
um
yeah so
so in terms of strychnine use um you
know i've always been curious about it
because
one thing that i've learned over the
years is almost any time somebody
classifies a substance as really really
bad or extremely dangerous it tends to
be the case that
it's at least partially misunderstood
and it wouldn't surprise me all that
much if maybe a very very low dose of
strychnine did elicit some kind of
desirable effect but obviously i am not
suggesting anyone listening to this uh
go out and try to evaluate that on their
own agreed we're not advocating for the
use of poisons to see with the
therapeutic dosage
i mentioned the case of salvia you know
we talked about medicinal plants before
we knew much about medicinal fungi and
then wasan comes back from ohako the
medicinal
mint
uh this was
stunning to the chemical world the
ethnobotanical world and i wonder what
you think that tells us about what's
still out there waiting to be discovered
yeah i love the story of salvia because
it was studied by
no shortage of brilliant researchers i
mean this was albert hoffman who had
little trouble isolating and then
synthesizing silicon and psilocybin he
obviously synthesized lsd he did a very
complicated work with ergolins and yet
when he was given a sample of salvia
divinorum he couldn't figure it out
and that was the case for many people
for many years they would make extracts
of it they would inject that extract
into a cat there's a mexican
psychiatrist named jose luis diaz who
did that work and it was clear that it
was having an effect on animals humans
tried it it was also
seemed clear it was having an effect but
the effect was somewhat subtle and part
of this had to do with the way that it
was administered usually as an aqueous
infusion um so
you know wassen tried it hoffman tried
it they said that there was some effect
that it was sort of mushroom like but
they couldn't quite put their finger on
it and
people were trying to figure out what is
this stuff what does it do if you
extract it inject it into a cat it does
something has a subtle effect in humans
what chemical is responsible for this
there's no nitrogenous alkaloid in it
that's responsible so what's going on
here and
i was actually talking to dennis mckenna
on my podcast recently and he told me a
really funny anecdote where he was
working for shaman pharmaceuticals and
he was studying extracts of
salvia and looking at their affinity for
the kappa opioid receptor and it was off
the charts and he thought okay this
doesn't make any sense there's no way
that this
plant contains something this potent i
must have made a mistake so he actually
discovered this but then discounted his
own finding because it seemed too
extraordinary to be real and it wasn't
until
uh brian roth actually started working
with
another
citizen scientist named daniel siebert
that they were able to definitively
demonstrate that the active principle of
salvia divinorum was salvanor in a
and that salvadorn a was an
extraordinarily potent and selective
agonist for the kappa opioid receptor
and that it was the most potent
naturally occurring psychedelic so that
is quite a curveball coming from a plant
that there was some ambiguity whether it
was active at all
well when i was in oaxaca and asked to
shaman about it she said i'm not going
to give it to you it's too strong and
you don't need it and uh eventually she
changed her mind but it was really very
unpleasant
and i i didn't feel a healing
result from it
but now that it's uh obtained such wide
popularity i have to say i i remain very
surprised
but it clearly is not
similar to many of the other
mind-altering substances that i've had
experiences with did you chew the leaves
or use an aqueous infusion no it was the
leaves yeah so that's how she
administered she said she didn't use it
much because it was so powerful
and it was like sort of a last ditch or
very serious cases
whereas as you point out that the
shamans often give you medicines when
you're not sick what we'd probably call
adaptogens or immunostimulants which 20
years ago
weren't words that were in common
parlance
but i i was just struck by how different
it was and how
unpleasant it was frankly and what was
it that you didn't like
i felt that i was underwater in the dark
for nine hours
i i i didn't feel a sort of healing
therapeutic effect it just was almost
like a punishment
so but i mean you know shamans will tell
you
if you want a light show go to
disneyland okay
if you take ayahuasca and you don't see
anything it doesn't mean it's not
working that the the behold the rematio
is giving you what you need and
sometimes you see the ninth dimension
and sometimes you just fall asleep but
you're getting out of it what you need
the plant knows that's what they say
so again i can't say that i was
disappointed because i didn't see
fireworks i mean i'm i'm
not a person who is seeking thrills this
way it's just that you know many times
we've all had experiences with these
substances where we felt battle for it
or felt relief or stressed or whatever
and you know sometimes you don't
sometimes maybe you feel a little worse
off kind of how i felt yeah so anyway i
want to wind up here but since you uh
brought up our friend dennis mckenna
dennis mckenna is organizing a
conference which we'll discuss among
other things the drunken uh the stoned
ape theory
first promulgated by his late brother
terence
and
at the same time we have people who are
putting forward the drunken monkey
theory and i wonder
what you think of of these
ideas that these mind-altering
substances may have played a fundamental
role in not only
human culture but human evolution the
stoned ape theory
which was put forward by terence mckenna
is of course stating that once we
discovered mushrooms whatever
mind-altering substances it created
consciousness and we began to wonder it
wasn't just about what's to eat or what
plant do i use when i get sick
the drunken monkey theory is that our
ancestors lived in the trees and the
ripest fruit would fall to the ground
which is the sweetest fruit which in
some cases is fermented fruit so they
were catching a buzz from alcohol
and so these are sort of presented as
different cases
but they kind of point in the same
direction
and so we can just talk about the stoned
ape theory as to whether mind altering
substances really played a fundamental
role or may have played a fundamental
role or may have played no role in the
evolution of consciousness culture
history and evolution
well evolutionarily i think the evidence
for that is pretty slim to non-existent
and
i think that terence mckenna is
sometimes taken too literally you know i
think of him as a poet i love everything
that he says and i think that a lot of
the things that he said were intended to
provoke people to cause them to really
think about these things and to value
them and i think that in that capacity
he was extraordinarily effective but
from an evolutionary biological
perspective that would not be my uh
first explanation for how consciousness
emerged in humans
that said
i think that
if today in our culture with all of the
distractions and all the things that
exist
we can still look to this experience and
see it as one of the most
momentous and amazing in an entire life
you think what would that have been like
if you didn't have all these
distractions if it's that if it's this
valuable to us now what would it have
been like in the past and if it
allows people to have religious
epiphanies and even start religions now
then what would it have been like in the
past and i think that it's reasonable to
assume that it might have been similar
that said i think that people get into
trouble when they
you know
try to explain everything with
psychedelics which is the the extreme
that people tend to go to they either
want to again back to these uh
polarizing dichotomies either
psychedelics are
purposeless and have no historical value
or they're the origin of consciousness
religion and everything else and i don't
doubt that they did play a role in some
ancient religions but uh the question is
how significant that role was and
yeah
so i want to thank you for your kindness
and your insights it's a pleasure to
listen to somebody so well spoken but i
want to conclude by asking you about
your mentor nicholas lunglitz and the
primatology of primatologists
yes
yeah i mean nicholas langlets is a
really brilliant medical doctor who then
became an anthropologist and he wrote a
book called neuropsychedelia which i
really admire which is a
anthropological analysis of
neuroscientific research on psychedelics
and he's really great at taking
a different perspective on these issues
and really asking questions about what
are the motivations for these people why
are they doing it what biases are
integrated into the work they do
and i
he then switched to doing a sort of meta
primatology analysis where he'd look at
the primatology of primatologists which
i thought was also really interesting
but i think he might get back into
psychedelics right now because when he
wrote neuropsychedelia this was somewhat
of a fringe issue you know he was
spending time with the
you know dozen or so researchers that
were doing this work like franz volen
wider but now it's hard for somebody to
keep track of it even if it's their
full-time job i mean by some estimates
there are hundreds of pharmaceutical
startups that are pursuing these things
therapeutically i am repeatedly amazed
by the proliferation of new scientific
papers and patents coming out on
psychedelics i mean this is
really expanding at a pace that has
never before been seen i mean only
rivaled by the 1960s and so it's good
that there are people carefully
monitoring what's happening because it's
an important time in history
last last question
uh timothy leary's legacy
and from your perspective
well i get like mckenna i think that
leary is somebody who's often
misunderstood and possibly taken too
literally i see
leary as a comedian and a very good one
at that i mean when i read his books
when i listen to him speak i'm
repeatedly struck by how hilarious he is
and uh
and i think that he was blamed for a lot
of the problems that emerged in relation
to psychedelic drug use because people
would say okay everything was going
right
this was all going to be a medicine and
then timothy leary came along and this
zealot wanted to
go on some kind of ego crusade to
create a counterculture that would
delegitimize psychedelics and
i think that's a really uncharitable
interpretation of what was going on i
mean i think that the history of
psychedelics had been profoundly elitist
and
timothy leary was somebody who wanted to
break with that tradition of elitism and
he wanted to say this experience was
good for me and i think it's going to be
good for you as well i have no reason to
say that this isn't going to be good for
you so in fact go for it um you know is
that the most responsible thing to have
done probably not but i think that there
was something honest about it and
something democratic about it and
something that
actually put faith in the intelligence
of the broader community whether or not
that was a good or bad idea
and if it hadn't been him it would have
been somebody else i think that's the
other thing to keep in mind with all
this you can't
hiding is a great short-term strategy
and it's a terrible long-term strategy
and if people think that these problems
are going to be solved by hiding or
being silent it's just not the case
maybe for one person for one generation
you can hide but if you want to see
progress in the long run you have to be
open you have to be honest and
ultimately what timothy leary did in the
long term is the right thing
because he was honest about what he felt
about these things he thought they were
amazing he wasn't going to hide that and
say oh no this is only for medical use
because he didn't believe that
and
i think that the same is true for these
conservation issues i remember somebody
criticizing me and saying well don't you
realize that by even talking about toad
conservation you're simply informing
more people about toads so what you
really should do is just not talk about
it and again that might be true if i
were the only person talking about it
but people are going to talk about it
whether i like it or not and so the
question is are you going to talk about
it responsibly
agreed
thank you very much this is great
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the 4-hour body this is more
than 10 years ago and i did not get paid
to do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multivitamins multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tip
[Applause]
you